and then we met trickster told him
working from Hamilton he said he knew
Canadian girl who had a thing for a man
Kim's i was on a bachelor trip our heads
exploded when we saw Drake's that across
the bar we took the photo with them we
celebrated afterward we sang some drake
songs and we carried on
the guys have a reason to celebrate the
song blows up online and trends on
twitter i was texting dennis the day
came out I was like Dennis you're way
more popular than I thought you were his
Hassan and Dennis grams not the only one
there writing about the band gets
personal opening up about romance and
relationships
for me it's you know writing about
friends and family but also you know
love right and and relationships you
have with your partner we made sure that
that we were always trying to inject
what was making us really excited at
that moment into the music every human
this so the guys are about to hit the
road for a national tour across Canada a
music scene they're proud to be part of
I think music and Canada is great we
love all the music that surrounds Drake
and the Toronto hip-hop scene I think
it's a good time to be just part of the
musical community because you can get
inspired by so many different things
selection